une réforme des retraites est nécessaire
parce que il y a devant nous deux faits
qui sont incontournables le premier
c'est dans les 10 prochaines années plus
de 150 milliards de déficit de notre
régime par répartition l'autre fait
incontournable c'est que on a toujours
plus de retraités de pensionnés toujours
moins de cotisants c'est un régime
intergénérationnel nous tenons justement
à ce lien entre les générations mais si
on ne fait rien il s'effondrera ce sera
la banqueroute ce sera le chacun pour
soi et à ce moment-là ce seront les
Français les plus modestes qui perdront
beaucoup
[Musique]
une philosophie de plus de justice plus
de justice c'est d'abord vis-à-vis des
femmes et vis-à-vis des maires de
famille les trois quarts des petites
retraites ce sont les femmes et les
maires de famille ont eu des enfants en
ayant des enfants elles ont considéré le
régime de retraite par répartition et
elles se sont pénalisées parce que une
carrière avec des interruptions de
maternité c'est souvent une moins bonne
carrière professionnelle que les hommes
et donc une plus petite retraite les
trois quarts des petites retraites ce
sont des femmes et bien nous nous
voulons voter un amendement qui
permettra de donner à ces maires de
famille qui ont eu au moins un enfant
une surcote de 5%. donc justice pour les
maires de famille justice aussi pour les
français si on demande des efforts aux
Français il faut être intraitable contre
la fraude et ce que nous voulons nous
c'est que par exemple il y a plus de
retraite qui soit versé à l'étranger
alors que on sait par ailleurs que ces
retraites qui sont versées à des
retraités ces retraités sont décédés
donc il faut des éléments de biométrique
qui soit infalctifiable
idem on veut durcir aussi les conditions
de résidence en France pour ceux et
celles qui touchent le minimum
vieillesse c'est la moindre des choses
on peut pas demander ces efforts aux
Français si on n'est pas plus rigoureux
dans la gestion des deniers publics
[Musique]